and get your poi to point I'm gonna use
to point now and again pick your your
your directions for me I've got whoa G
what's in that oh the dome that's the
dome okay so I've got the dome in that
direction to my right I've got a big
crane to my left I've got a big museum
and back here I've got the video camera
so I need you to pick your things and be
consistent with them that's gonna help
you
so get your poi flying with me we're
gonna face this way for me it's the
crane for you as you practice you
practice pick your consistent thing so
you got the play going forward towards
the crane
okay great now in front of us for me
when I'm facing the dome there's a I'm
gonna mention there's a golf ball
between my posts then back here I'm
circling away from the museum so we have
the crane we're coming down the crane
towards the crane there's a golf ball
you can do this with me it's a golf ball
at the toes whack the golf ball whack
the golf ball whack the golf ball can
whack the golf ball and then you're
going away from the museum you can put
that together like this we're circling
towards the cranes as the player coming
down the cranes all you're gonna do is
relax and let your body turn towards
museum your eternal all the way
no the dome I'm gonna turn all the way
to the museum I'm it's just like I'm
gonna whack a golf ball and follow
through I'm gonna go whack and I follow
through I turn all the way and I'm look
I'm magically going backwards facing
museum now if I hesitate it's gonna go
like this
I'm gonna crack it if I hesitate it's
gonna get all tangled so don't eat so
what you want to do is really relax and
follow through and go black and if
you're relaxed and your hands are stay
with your hips you don't cross your
hands will be here here the hands really
stay on their own side you'll turn all
the way back and you'll be going
backwards
then you imagine there's a rainbow so
for me I imagine there's a rainbow going
over the dome I let my hands outside
play come up the museum I let my hands
and the POE just trace to me the rainbow
follow rainbow and I get all the way
back to the Krantz so I can whack a golf
ball and follow a rainbow black a golf
ball and follow a rainbow then I'm gonna
shift my feet so my toes are pointing
towards you I mean this now I'm being
and this is where you need to be
consistent because if I were to switch
directions I'm practice like this I'm
facing the other direction but I'm
technically practicing the same turn and
I want to practice the other half of the
turn so I need the I'm going down it
doesn't matter which my feet are facing
my player coming down the cranes and
going forward towards the cranes so now
I go past the golf ball on your side of
the camera and then I follow a rainbow
over the camera golf ball past the
camera rainbow over the camera shift my
feet golf ball past the dome rainbow
over the dome or I can go aside to do
this golf ball past the dome rainbow
over the camera golf ball past the dome
rainbow over the camera golf ball past
the camera rainbow over the dome golf
ball
rainbow golf ball rainbow golf ball
rainbow golf ball rainbow it's okay this
week if that's a bit awkward it'll take
a little it'll take practice hopefully
you'll be able to put them together and
go golf ball rainbow and that's a full
pirouette golf ball rainbow golf ball
rainbow you don't have to do that this
week we'll come back to that next week
but if it happens awesome this week guys
want to make sure you can do a golf ball
and a rainbow and in the other side a
golf ball and a rainbow and then a golf
ball keep turning to the left for a
rainbow
golf ball turning to your right shoulder
rainbow turning your right shoulder and
as long as you're consistent if you keep
thinking okay there's my landmark and I
always going to start forwards towards
it landmark and then I'm going to shift
my feet either to turn to my left or to
my right as long as you're starting with
that landmark you will you will know how
to go through all the possibilities and
and then we're going to build on each
week and so that should I'm hoping that
should be working usually that works so
if it doesn't work show me what's
happening